if you're like me then you like to take
your switch with you and play it
everywhere on your tv
airplanes while you're laying in bed at
2am and should be sleeping or while
you're pooping
i mean if you really want to keep
watching you can
so that means when i have the option and
a game is multi-platform i tend to favor
picking it up on my switch
you know because of the whole pooping
thing but as we all know this machine is
a little behind the xbox series x slash
s and ps5
and playstation 4 and xbox one so with
gta trilogy the definitive edition just
having released the question is should
you pick it up on the switch i mean
they're old games from the ps2 era what
could possibly go wrong
oh my god
oh no
oh no
to quickly save you some time if you
plan to play the game portably then sure
why not it's a serviceable enough
version
but if you plan to primarily play the
game docked and on your tv then
no
definitely go with another version
i'm saying that up front so hey for
those of you who don't want to blow the
video to give you a quick answer i'm
saving you some time but if you'd like
to know why here's the deal while these
are ps2 remakes the graphics were
enhanced even if some of the results
were
uh
let's say unintentionally hilarious at
times
but the graphics are far better on the
non-switch versions and honestly while i
know it's not as powerful of a system i
don't totally understand why as the
graphics for the gta trilogy don't
exactly seem all that great
i mean take crash bandicoot insane
trilogy the graphics for that look far
more impressive than gta although
granted a giant open world isn't being
loaded at once but still the game looks
similar enough on the switch
but if you compare the gta trilogy
everything looks much better outside of
the switch especially the environments
when i was playing vice city on my ps5
with those sweet pink and blue retro 80s
tones coming in from the sky vice city
actually looked pretty gorgeous that was
when the game truly shone and it felt
like an actual enhancement from the
original games meanwhile on my switch
it just doesn't look as impressive
on top of that despite having worse
graphics the loading times were also
slightly worse on the switch
there's a ghosting issue on both
versions where you can see ghosting
behind your car and it's especially
noticeable behind a motorcycle and this
issue seemed to be more pronounced on
the switch
additionally the draw distance on
objects like cars you might run into or
ramps you might shoot off of is
unreasonably bad the switch also doesn't
have as many graphic modes that you can
adjust compared to other versions on my
ps5 i could turn on and off lens flare
motion blur and depth of field whereas
none of these settings are available on
the switch additionally you can toggle
between performance and fidelity
graphics modes so if the game is getting
a little laggy on fidelity mode just
flip on performance mode and you should
be good to go
but if you're like me and don't care too
much about graphics there is another
far more major issue i ran into
and that was a consistent frame drop and
lag while driving around the city in any
of the gta games it didn't matter if i
was driving around liberty city
vice city
[Music]
you could be certain that i would
consistently be battling against lag no
matter how much i tried to adjust the
graphical setting to try and make the
game run better and for a game series
called grand theft auto where the
primary thing you're doing uh in between
murdering people with chainsaws getting
hookers and blowing up buildings is
driving that's really what the core of
the game has been and this frame drop
issue was brutal when you're chasing
down and trying to run over a pizza man
within a strict time limit who somehow
delivers his pizzas by randomly throwing
them at the ground the last thing you
want to worry about is the lag and frame
drops causing you to crash into another
set of cars it was honestly that bad and
that frustrating and this lag i'm
showing you wasn't even the worst case
i'm going to show you my footage
unedited from vice city's mission
demolition man where i had to blow up a
building
with
what
meanwhile this is how it looks on a ps5
so given all of this
why am i giving the game a pass on the
switch
that was good timing specifically it's
because oddly enough the game actually
runs better in handheld mode i first
played the game docked so i could record
footage and wrongly assumed that would
be the best way to play the game
but once i later hopped in bed to play
the game suddenly the lag and frame
drops while driving were gone i did go
ahead and replay the game all the way
through the demolition man stage just to
test out blowing up the building again
as that was the worst case of frame
drops and
it still had frame drops during the
explosion
but up until then the game had performed
reasonably well i was actually pretty
satisfied with it and when i later
booted up gta san andreas oh [ __ ] here
we go again i didn't have any noticeable
issues
at least in the limited time i played it
to be perfectly transparent i didn't get
early access so i purchased the game on
the switch and got a review code for the
ps5 day of and i tried to play a decent
chunk of all three games on both systems
so i could do my best to accurately
compare them so in the end if you're
dying to play the gta trilogy on your
switch handheld
it's okay and while the frame drops in
dock mode are super annoying and
definitely not something i'm giving a
pass the game is still playable while
docked so if the nintendo switch is your
only option
hey you can still play it on the switch
but if you do want to play the game on a
tv primarily
yeah i'd say skip the switch version and
enjoy laughing at the ridiculous
character models that also exist in the
ps5 version of the game i hope this
helped and i'll see you guys next time
peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
you